so Felicity congratulations on a
wonderful performance what an honor to
play this woman have you found even more
of a voice for yourself as a woman but
also as an actress after playing this
role absolutely absolutely if there's
one thing I've learnt from this film is
is how important is to stand up for what
you believe in and to find your voice
and definitely that's come from from
Ruth Bader Ginsburg someone who has
tirelessly argued for her beliefs and
has made great change through that so I
yeah I carry her with me everywhere I go
I'm sure you were fortunate enough to be
invited into her home yeah what was that
like what kind of insight did you gain
into her life but also did she show you
her collection of collars yes yeah she's
really what's a little fantastic is
she's in this moment of great of great
Fame and and popularity and rightly so
because she's worked really hard to get
to the position that she's in so I just
felt her enjoyment of it and and she was
incredibly welcoming we sat and drank
coffee together we looked around her
apartment it's covered in pictures of
her friends and family and little
mementos that fans have sent her and and
she doesn't she doesn't take it for
granted for it for a second the position
that she's in why was it important why
was it essential to have a female
director and why was Mimi the right
person well it was just really important
to have someone who had empathy for that
story and and and Mimi has been through
very similar experiences herself but
also she is she's an incredibly
experienced director I mean vast
experience particularly in action films
which was perfect for this film because
it had to have a pace it had to have
attention to it very much when Daniel
set out writing it he wanted it to be
entertaining he wanted it to be a
feel-good film and and for people to
enjoy the experience of watching it and
me someone who's shown that she can do
that in space was sexism something that
you had experienced in your career do
you feel like that times have changed
since Ruth has come along yeah I think
um I think what I was able to channel
through Ruth was that feeling of being
in the minority of going off on film
sets and often being one of a few women
on
set so I definitely understood what it
feels like to be a bit of an outsider as
she felt in those in those moments
tell us about shooting in our beloved
Canadian city of Montreal oh we love
Montreal we absolutely adored it we just
spent all that time obviously when we
weren't working going out for dinners
the food is fantastic um I have a really
good friend good old friend he lives
there so we'd often find ourselves going
to ballet classes and things like that
but it's a wonderful wonderful city